hello friends I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update let's be honest
here we're all thinking the same thing a
sequel to avatar we're thinking why we
pretty much wrapped it up in the first
one given that it's already basically
the plot of Pocahontas that means that
the sequel should be a straight-to-dvd
mess that's basically an excuse to draw
Jake Sully in pretty English dresses
much has happened in the world of
blockbuster movies since James Cameron's
pioneering sci-fi adventure avatar was
released at the end of two thousand nine
including an unstoppable wave of
superhero films and entire Hobbit
trilogy and the rejuvenation of the Star
Wars saga but avatar remains the biggest
box office draw of all time and the
long-promised sequels will soon be on
their way now Cameron has provided an
update on their status speaking to
Entertainment Weekly Cameron explained
the decision to shoot no fewer than
three sequels back-to-back has meant a
lengthy pre-production process I'm in
the process of doing another pass
through all scripts right now who said
the design process is very mature at
this point we've been designing for
about a year and a half all the
characters settings and creatures are
all pretty much set avatar 2 is
currently scheduled for a December 2017
release the first film earned 2.7
billion dollars worldwide making it the
most successful movie ever made in terms
of box-office spend ahead of Titanic
which was also directed by cameron do
you think Avatar needs a new sequel do
you even care about any films outside of
Star Wars right now let us know in the
comments I'm Katie you can find me on
Twitter and how not to draw and remember
to keep it gamespot com for all your
gaming and entertainment news